sixty plus blank is equal to ninety
well one way to think about it
sixty is the same thing as six tens
ninety is the same thing as nine tens
so six tens plus how many tens is going
to equal nine tens
well six plus three is nine so six tens
plus three tens
three tens which is the same thing as 30
is going to be equal to 90. so if you
look at it the other way around
90 minus 60 is going to be what
well nine tens minus six tens is going
to be three tens
let's keep going let's do more of these
okay they say 80 minus 40.
well 80 is the same thing as 8 tens and
they have both of them in red
40 is the same thing as how many tens
well we have a 4 in the tens place 40 is
the same thing as 4 tens
so 80 minus 40 is the same thing is
equal to
8 tens 8 tens minus 4 tens
8 tens minus 4 tens
so eight tens minus four tens is the
same thing as well what's eight minus
four eight minus four is four
eight tens minus four tens is four tens
well what's another way of writing four
tens well we can write that as
forty
let's keep going this is a lot of fun
more fun than i expected
all right another one just like that
ninety is nine tens
sixty is
six tens
so ninety minus sixty is equal to
nine tens minus six tens nine tens is
the same thing as ninety six tens is the
same thing as sixty
well what's nine tens minus six tens
well it's going to be three tens so 90
minus 60 is equal to three tens well
another way of writing three tens is
thirty so we could also write ninety
minus sixty is equal to
30.